[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
moi je vais commencer par parler de moi
de mon grand réveil de ce qui s'est
passé
tout d'abord je m'appelle oui puis non
je n'ai le 3 octobre 1997
je suis un élève issia le stp en
première année et je vous parlais de mon
enfance comment j'étais avant
j'ai eu la chance de vivre dans une
famille aimante j'ai pas eu de problèmes
de famille tout s'est très bien passé de
ce côté là par contre j'étais très
introverti j'avais très peu confiance en
moi je regardais toujours l'action avant
de l'effectuer
pour ceux qui connaissent le texte
loterie de faux j'étais cet acteur je
suivais les autres et je n'ai fait que
tu aies pas par moi même pour moi la vie
avait un but précis qui mettait dictée
on essaie et on agissait selon les codes
qui nous était imposé
maintenant avec le recul je vois bien
que cette vision est erronée que iliad
un problème dans le fait d'accepter ce
que je suis en train de faire et toute
cette vision a été remis en cause par
mon grand réveil
maintenant je vous parlais d'une de mes
passions la natation natation
certains pensent que c'est ennuyeux qui
ça n'a pas forcément intérêt la speaker
précédente pas vous le confirmer mais
pour moi c'est un moyen je vais pas dire
d'expression mais de se défouler ce qui
est bien avec la natation c'est
lorsqu'on âge notre esprit se libère
libéré on n'a pas de contrainte
on peut réfléchir notre vision à nos
projets qu'est ce qui nous motive
qu'est ce qui nous agace que ce qui nous
embête et avec la natation ça permet
d'avoir une réflexion sur soi j'ai eu la
chance de faire la nation très jeune
j'ai fait les bébés nageurs
puis le loisir je passais par les
compétitions et cette éducation de la
natation a été important dans mon
développement
de plus je fais je travaille un petit
peu l'apnée lorsqu'on âge on apprend à
retenir son souffle et l'apnée donc
importante ce qui est assez intéressant
dans la cne c'est qu'elle nécessite une
maîtrise de soi on doit savoir doit se
connaître
pouvoir se gérer pouvoir être à l'aise
dans l'eau et le fait d'être en apnée
provoque une sensation de légèreté
on est comme en apesanteur on se
recentre sur soi il y a même un mot qui
définit le risque de 2,7 de cet état de
plénitude
l'ivresse des profondeurs maintenant je
vous parlais d'un événement qui s'est
passé le 11 octobre 2014 jeune âge et
j'avais un entraînement de natation
comme tous les samedis après un effort
intense de trois quarts d'heure on
enchaîne sur la cession d'apnée alors la
session d'apnée il ya 2 10 appelé
différentes
l'apnée statique et l'apnée dynamique on
commence par une année dite static c'est
lorsqu'on reste dans l'eau immergée sans
bouger on enchaîne donc on me fait des
paliers 10 secondes 30 secondes une
minute et puis ensuite on fait un palier
à temps libre à ce moment là j'ai
effectué une apnée de 2 minutes 30
c'est pas trop mal mais par rapport au
procès dérisoire ensuite on enchaîne sur
une apnée dynamique
peut-être par excès de confiance je me
dis que je dois faire cinquante mètres
une apt et dynamique c'est lorsqu'on h
où l'eau 50 m c'est pour la plupart des
piscines un aller retour et donc j'ai
effectué mes cinquante mètres tout se
passe bien au début je fais 25
je repars de l'autre sens arrivé aux
trois quarts je sens je commence à
manquer de souffle j'avais déjà fait un
effort intense
il me reste quelques mètres dizaines de
mètres je me dis psychologiquement je
vais y arriver ça peut passer je forge
force
allez c'est parti le problème efforts
intenses manque d'oxygène malaise vagal
lorsqu'on a un malaise vagal on se noie
lorsqu'on se noie on appelle ça une 50
à la fin de cet entraînement
les cours repartent le public arrive et
on me voit pas tout de suite
une personne âgée passe au dessus de moi
et voit quelque chose au fond il ya un
problème on appelle les maîtres nageurs
ils me sortent de l'eau et meurent et
anime maintenant j'ai parlé du côté
scientifique de la chose j'ai eu ce
qu'on peut dire comme un arrêt cardiaque
mais comment définir cette mort il y a
deux mordre deux types de mort la mort
dit clinique elle passe par trois stades
arrêt de la conscience comme un
évanouissement arrêt pulmonaire de l'eau
dans les poumons arrêt cardiaque
le sang ne circule plus mais la vraie
mort qu'est ce que la vraie mort la
vraie mort est défini selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
comme un état irréversible des capacités
cérébrales qui sont à la cause des
réflexes ainsi on peut définir un état
entre la mort clinique
l'arrêt cardiaque et la mort cérébrale
car lorsque notre coeur s'arrête il ya
une possibilité que notre cerveau
continuer à fonctionner maintenant je
vais vous exprimer des faits dépenser
certaines personnes pensent qu' il y a
pendant cet état intermédiaire entre la
mort clinique et la mort cérébrale notre
cerveau accroît ses capacités
on peut on peut penser que notre cerveau
qui régit l'ensemble de notre corps
lorsqu'il est libéré de la conscience de
l'activité pulmonaire et de l'activité
cardiovasculaires se développe elle n'a
pu tout ce frein et ses capacités sont
augmentés
comme vous le savez on n'utilise pas
100% de nos capacités intellectuelles
100% de mes capacités cérébrales
donc on pense que cet effet permet
d'augmenter la capelle
c'est cérébrale d étude corrobore ces
faits la première c'est qu'on remarque
lors d'un arrêt cardiaque qui lie à une
augmentation de l'activité cérébrale et
cette augmentation de l'activité
cérébrale 3 traduit bien qu'il se passe
quelque chose il se passe quelque chose
entre cette mort clinique
et cette mort cérébrale il y a une autre
raison dé la présence d'éléments
chimiques
cette présence d'éléments chimiques
dopamine sérotonine et endorphines qui
sont donc oser un effort intense
l'appeler être bien lorsqu'on fait du
sport active une partie du cerveau le
lobe frontal
de plus le fait de manquer d'oxygène
d'avoir beaucoup de co2 dans l'organisme
développe et active encore plus cette
région du cerveau et cette région du
cerveau
elle est spécifique à l'imagination à
aux rêves et aux hallucinations
alors qu'est-ce qu'il se passe pendant
cette période entre la mort clinique et
la mort cérébrale on rêve trans plane on
voit la lumière
je vous rassure pour ma part rien de
tout ça j'ai pas vu la lumière j'ai pas
transposé je me suis pas vu à
l'extérieur mais il s'est passé quelque
chose car membres réveillant je savais
qu'il s'était passé quelque chose je
dois vous aviez je dois vous avouer que
la première fois que au moment où pardon
je me suis réveillé la première chose
que j'ai pensé c'est je me faire
défoncer par ma mère excusez moi pour
les mots mais c'est beau pour mot ce que
j'ai pensé
la deuxième chose c'est je sais que j'ai
rêvé je sais qu'il s'est passé quelque
chose
c'est en se réveillant c'était la
deuxième idée que j'ai eu et j'ai dû
dans un premier temps j'ai eu du mal à
mettre les mots sur ce qui s'est passé
sur ce que j'ai rêvé est la chose la
plus concrète que je peux vous montrer
c'est ce tableau de jo el qaria qui
exprime ce que j'ai vécu pour moi
j'avais cette sensation de
show de plénitude j'avais ces couleurs
rouge et noir s'est très comme lorsqu'on
fait un très fort les yeux et qu'on a
ces images la même chose est l'événement
qui peut se rapporter le rêve que je
peux illustré par rapport à ce que j'ai
vécu c'est un train foetus dans le
ventre de sa mère le parallèle est quand
même assez judicieux puisque nous sommes
dans l'eau la température de l'eau est
idéal on est sous l'eau on est en agde
gravité pesanteur sensation de plénitude
ce qui ce que j'ai vécu le fait de faire
ce parallèle je ne sais pas si je les
vraiment vécu je sais pas c'est le fait
après post traumatique ou gelée
conceptualiser où c'est ce que j'ai
vraiment vécu ça je ne peux pas vous le
dire est ce que je sais c'est que j'ai
vécu quelque chose j'ai senti quelque
chose
certains vous parleront d'expérience
surnaturel pour moi c'était une
sensation est une autre chose qui peut
corroborer ce que je voulais exprimer
c'est lorsqu'on m'a réanimer j'étais
inconscient je me suis levé agenouillé
et remy allongée il s'est donc passé
quelque chose et j'en suis sûr pour moi
ça ça a été le grand réveil
maintenant qu'est ce que ça a changé
quelle est la valeur ajoutée à ce que
j'ai eus quel est l'événement qu'elle
est comment cet événement a changé ma
vision
il y a deux choses principales la
première relativiser la période post
traumatique s'est très bien déroulé la
pelote période post-traumatique c'est
après l'accident
je suis retourné dans l'eau deux mois
après j'ai recommencé l'apnée six mois
après je passais mon diplôme de maître
nageur sauveteur un an et demi après
j'ai pu retourner dans l'eau assez
rapidement et reprendre du plaisir à ce
que j'ai fait pour moi cet événement
n'avait était important mais n'avait pas
de conséquence notable s'était passé il
fallait avancer et le fait de
relativiser donne de nouveau challenge
on peut se dire on va faire ça et on va
y aller
quoi qu'il arrive la deuxième chose et
le rapport à la vie comme je vous ai dit
précédemment
pendant l'enfance très introverti
fait justement de cet accident m'a donné
de la force pour pouvoir avancer et
m'exprimer je lui à force de faire la
une classe préparatoire
j'ai eu la force de rentrer à los tp et
la deux et cette force n'a permis aussi
de me découvrir de me faire beau
d'élargir mon cercle d'amis d'être de
prendre du plaisir avec ses amis et
pouvoir sortir m'amuser faire des
projets ensemble et m'éclater tout
simplement maintenant cette notion du
grand réveil mais personnel chacun un
événement qui révèle en lui le grand
réveil pour certaines personnes ça peut
être la naissance d'un enfant
on voit bien un changement notable de
notre façon d'être
lorsqu'on a un enfant pour d'autres ça
peut être un accident ou malheureux ou
heureux ou pour d'autres simplement le
fait de se réveiller tous les matins et
ce grand réveil change notre vision
le dernier mot que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'avant j'étais spectateur et
maintenant je suis acteur et j'aimerais
qu'il soit pas époux je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]